did you know that Netflix is making a
docudrama about Cleopatra
that doesn't seem particularly unusual
Cleopatra is a very important historical
figure
what's strange about the docudrama is
that they've decided to cast a black
woman as Cleopatra
the docudram is called African queens
Queen Cleopatra and so I I can
understand you you hear African and some
people who don't know about the history
of Africa the difference between North
Africa and sub-Saharan Africa you might
think well African that must mean that
she's African but Cleopatra very much
was not African she was Macedonian Greek
this is not particularly controversial
and they cast a black actress to play
her
this is not complicated
this is just about antipathy toward
white people a while ago there was a
conservative who posted on Twitter and
said that daily wire's new movie Project
was going to be a biography a biopic of
Malcolm X and it was going to storm me
and everyone laughed because that would
be ridiculous I don't think that I'm
going to be playing Malcolm X I don't
think that uh Ryan Gosling is going to
be playing Martin Luther King Jr anytime
soon if this happened Not only would
people laugh at it but of course there'd
be a national uproar film studios would
shut down people would burn Effigies and
set the country on fire
and in the other direction
it doesn't matter this isn't hypocrisy
this is just antipathy toward white
people in our culture you see this
enshrined in the law white people are
basically the only group that Asians
fall into it a little bit too of of
people against whom you can discriminate
on the basis of race that's true in
college admissions that's true in
employment and it's true in our popular
culture white people are the only race
that you are encouraged to insult and
make fun of and deride it's not only
acceptable but actually encouraged in
our culture and that's just the way it
is
and that's what this is about this is
why Cleopatra can be played by a black
woman but I will not be able to play
Malcolm X in the new biopic
this is not to say that you can never
have any race bending in movies a great
example of I I felt perfectly suitable
race spending was the Denzel Washington
Macbeth movie which is one of maybe the
greatest performance of Macbeth I've
ever seen and the reason this was I felt
totally fine is because we're not
talking about a history here we're not
talking about a biopic or a docudrama
we're talking about a very famous play
we're talking about Shakespeare
who is the most important playwright in
the English language and one of the
aspects of Shakespeare that that has
made him so important is that he writes
about The Human Experience
and so while there are different races
of people in his plays that's secondary
to what he's saying about human nature
the other reason it didn't really matter
all that much is Denzel is just such an
incredible actor that
I just want to see the guy play Macbeth
he's just a very very good actor and it
wasn't distracting and it in no way did
this casting decision detract from the
play
here we're talking about and historic
not only an historical figure but a
docued rama so if you know you're just
completely rewriting history which is
what the libs do all the time we're
going to need to tell each other about
Real History okay we're gonna need to
talk about it when you want to talk you
got to check out pure talk right now go
to puretalk.com use promo code Knowles
tax season is here you want to make your
accountant happy I got one super easy
way to do it switch to pure talk instead
of paying a fortune to Verizon ATT or
T-Mobile cut your bill in half with pure
talk Pure Talk offers unlimited talk
text and plenty of data starting at just
30 bucks a month and saving the average
family over 900 a year a lot of people
think the bigger the provider the better
the service let me fill you in on a
little secret Pure Talk uses the same
network not saying a comparable Network
I'm saying the exact same network for
less there's no contract no hidden fees
no hassle switch over to Pure Talk in as
little as 10 minutes while keeping your
phone your phone number they're us-based
customer service team
worth the switch just for the us-based
customer service team make that switch
really really easy pure talks so sure
you're going to love the service they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee your first month is guaranteed
risk free go to puretalk.com enter promo
code knows to save 50 off your first
month puretalk.com promo code nulls Pure
Talk is simply smarter Wireless
speaking of more racial politics
leftist Congress lady pramila jayapal
I'm probably mispronouncing that but
there it goes
a congresswoman jayapal is arguing for
U.S amnesty for millions of illegal
aliens Millions really probably tens of
millions of illegal aliens and what's
her argument why do we need to give a
bunch of foreign Nationals who are in
our country illegally why do we need to
give them amnesty
well she says
America needs immigrants
in order to survive
quote immigrants pick the food we eat
clean our homes she goes on to list a
number of other service industry jobs
and you hear this line all the time
these are the two most shallow left-wing
arguments on immigration they'll say
well without immigration you couldn't
get tacos could you imagine a world
without Chinese food that's why we need
to open up our borders and flood our
country with three million foreigners
every year well we can welcome some
people in with just completely Opening
Our borders I think we've got enough
Taco stands I I like tacos as much as
the next guy we're good I think we've
saturated the Taco Market we don't need
to ignore our laws disrupt our social
order upend our self-governing Republic
in order to get another Taco I think
we're good on that but then the other
argument they make is they say well
there are jobs that Americans won't do
if we don't let desperate foreigners in
who are who's going to scrub our toilets
which is offensive to everybody because
it insinuates that Americans
won't clean Americans are are pretty
cleanly people
if you've ever traveled to Europe for
instance you'll notice that Americans
are almost neurotically hygienic
compared to Europeans certainly compared
to really everybody in the world
I haven't traveled extensively through
any other places so my frame of
reference is Europe but I've heard that
China is not the most sanitary place I
did go to India once not all that clean
I've never been to Africa but I've heard
it's not
not the most enjoyable experience when
it comes to basic sanitation so no I
think America we could clean our own
bathrooms if we wanted to that's not an
argument for for breaking the law
need them to to pick our food I think
Americans can pick food they can do that
but but then it's offensive in the other
way too because immigrants believe it or
not can can do things other than clean
our toilets
immigrants even from those poor
countries in Latin America or Middle
East or Africa or anywhere else
believe it or not they're human
they can do other jobs they don't just
need to pick grapes and scrub our
bathrooms they can do other things it's
so
patronizing condescending dehumanizing
it's it's a it's a perfect Democrat
political argument
because
it is deeply offensive to everybody
and and not terribly persuasive man how
insightful was that that was a great
clip you can get more Great Clips you
can get the whole show by subscribing
ring that Bell click that button do that
thing and subscribe to the Michael
Nelson YouTube channel see you next time
[Music]
oh
foreign